screw it I'm back I want to play more I
have no other reason besides that so I'm
gonna do it
um I think I did the mark of the
apartment might as well do the house
because why not and if I get through
this on the first try then I'll go ahead
and do the bank and I don't think I'll
go back and do the other ones but
whatever all I have to do is I have to
report anomalies as they happen which is
going to be freaking difficult
considering just how many things are
here
oh boy anomalies have been previously
detected
oh God why did I even bother to do this
there's so many things in the house
there's no way I would ever be able to
discover them all okay there's another
thing there there okay I just gotta keep
sweeping man Seattle oh and this is the
one where you gotta look outside too
where you gotta report like something's
outside if something's actually outside
so not only do I have to look everything
in here I have to look at the windows
why did I even do this why did I want to
go here I'm not going to be able to
remember this wallpaper
this interior decorating is atrocious
everything about it
awful yeah I was I was really uh really
ambitious saying first try wasn't I
I was really overly ambitious there's no
way
was that pillow always on the bed I
don't know I didn't even look at the bed
before why do all the light switches
have lights on them
what is anything why am I so
flabbergasted is that TV always tiny
was there even a TV there before how
would I know
not like I looked I have no hope I'm
doomed
I'm doom already I'm about to get the
message saying there's multiple
anomalies and I'm like oh I don't know
yep there it is how did I know that was
coming
I'm I'm just gonna say maybe bedroom
because who knows
maybe that pillow wasn't there before
maybe the bed was more properly made
nope I'm doomed hi I'm mama Markiplier
and this video is sponsored by dislike
first off I'd like to thank the newest
Gods to join the game Athena and Nyx for
giving me a chance this light is an
incredible audio and visual experience
and it features amazing graphics with
Heroes rendered in movie level CG shorts
all with exclusive original music click
the link in the description below to
download dislike today and who knows
maybe in the near future you might just
find me
looking forward
in this game this light local YouTuber
Markiplier has been reported missing
rumors are circulating that he's been
found in the card RPG game dislike
alongside gods for multiple
civilizations and mythologies such as
Zeus Odin and Anubis but how all these
Gods could be in one mobile game is
unknown
however multiple reports have identified
Persons of Interest Athena and Nyx who
may be responsible for Markiplier
head to social media to vote on what my
character's vo lines should be we now
return you back to your originally
scheduled programming
I see nothing
I'm blind
I have no eyeballs I see nothing
parlor
damn it
it's over all right I'm going back in
well you don't have to say it like that
two pillows on that one three pillows on
that one two speakers
uh we got pots and pans over on the left
there this is an old house that dude's
there things on the Shelf up top plant
in a Vaz
as for me in my house we will serve the
Lord
five poker chips two crosses for every
house is built by someone but the
Builder of all things is good the
Builder of this game is a demon
wait a minute wait the TV is different
in the in the Leisure room that that's
not right
that's not right oh I got one I can't
believe it but I got one
okay was there always a candelabra here
something about this room does not rub
me right
I'm gonna report it because I have some
to burn
I don't think so
nope okay well I wasted time there
nothing outside seems abnormal three
pillows two pillows
uh Grill's still out there trash cans
still there these pots those things that
painting the saying is the same
candelabra
how would I ever notice the candelabras
I'm screwing myself aren't I I'm screwed
damn I'm boned
uh there's a Voz up on the top of that
radio paintings
there's a beer in the cup holder three
cups over there's something in the
corner there that probably was there
before I think it was
a suitcase was there a bedroom seems
right for a suitcase
oh God stop that
God
how
what why it's a book on by the
Candelabra there penis is the same the
toilet seat is down wait a minute that's
so specific
that was up before that was up before
hoop
get that back up we don't put the toilet
seat around down around here we don't do
that we don't do that
that's so specific
God that's so specific uh Grill is still
there this dude's still there that's
still there this is all still fine this
is all still fine that was never lit
there's a lampshade back there paintings
are still the same clock's still ticking
it says it's like oh that actually
accurately reflects the time that's
fascinating
these chairs like this
was that chair a chair chair different
chair uh maybe
Maybe
I don't know if it's gonna give me a
warning again if there's multiple if
there's almost too many anomalies
probably
not probably not one boss in the corner
there this creepy dude I feel like
there's something missing here but uh I
can't speak to it I feel like there's
something missing there if I feel like
there's something missing that probably
is something missing frick
damn it
ah it's not gonna tell me is it it's not
gonna tell me if I get it wrong or it's
not going to tell me if I die and then
don't do it there's a loaf of bread was
that always there I don't know
[Music]
by monitors too big
time G monitor but then I wouldn't be
able to see any of the details I'm boned
I'm dead I'm dead I'm so dead I'm dead
I'm dead there's bottles under the
whatever that is I'm dead red I'm dead
I'm dead bench
what was that
oh
I fixed two uh marginal Improvement okay
but I got a better understanding of the
house I need to I need to see where I
went wrong
I feel like it was either the chair
there's always bread there
these two chairs are the same there's a
bench over there there was a chair
missing I had a feeling it was but I
didn't want to okay there's three
there's four chairs three of one type
one of the other no chairs well once
you're in the left corner there
one chair
now I'm too focused on the chairs
pictures there two paintings there
oh my God
hi
hello that's not right
that wasn't right at all
at least that was an obvious one
I mean I might be on observant sometimes
but I think even I'd notice it
decapitated the head in my bedroom
my bathroom whatever I don't even know
what room it was
you hear that
outside of Henry's barking
heard like a whisper
what was that
what was that no no no no no no no no no
no
was that always no was it
I knew it I knew it that bad I I knew it
that's not what the poker chips were
is it
something about this doesn't oh frick
that was what it was
oh would they I guess would they really
have changed the poker chips that would
be really minute
oh that's that's different that painting
is not the same
that is odd
okay toilet anomaly is fixed good good
good good
I haven't gotten the two anomaly or
three or whatever warning yet
if it's something outside I would never
know
I've not been looking outside at all and
I feel if I like if I start except for
the grill here I do notice that
I feel like if I start I'm going to lose
everything
I'm gonna lose everything anyway but
oh whoa that guy was creepy before I
didn't
that guy was creepy already I don't know
why
I don't know why they feel they need to
change it so subtly to that so far it's
been nothing but paintings it's the same
it's horrible either way how did I
notice that
I'm just that goddamn good
oh was that rug always that rug
that
that doesn't look right
no that was always the same oh no that
was always the same
never mind
what changed
I don't know what you changed but I did
it and I'm a genius
lexian put up a side by side of that
room and tell me what the hell it was
thank you
well somehow I'm at two o'clock I have
not had the multiple anomaly warning yet
I didn't even notice that painting there
okay well there's a painting there now I
never existed in my brain
bad trash cans different guys guys die
trash cans nah right that's too modern
oh hi
okay well if you're just gonna be
painting ones
feel like you could get a little more
creative than that but uh to each their
own fair enough do what you do
those chairs
ha
why are the chairs facing me why are the
chairs facing me I didn't even notice
the chairs before but I definitely
noticed that they're facing me that's
not right
thank you
slightly perturbing but not too bad I
think I'm on top of all of the anomalies
as in I haven't overlooked one
I think
if it's the wallpaper I'm I'm so boned
what is with the floor
wait a minute
did the floor always have
scuffed linoleum like that
it did I'm just dumb never noticed a
goddamn floor
oh I'm boned
Because unless something is very very
specific I have no chances left
whoa pillows pillows pillows pillows
pillows pillows there were three over
there I know because two and three I
can't believe I know that but I know
that
ha
okay I'm getting in a better pattern of
just looking at all the why oh hey how
you doing
okay you don't need no no
no oh my God
what the hell
oh man that's what happened to me in the
other game I got sucked into The Ether
and it almost happened to me again
foreign
okay that's what you don't want
you don't want to get sucked into the
other verse
that would be a horrible way to game
over
yeah but it could have been cool though
lyxian please look up someone else
playing and uh getting that particular
thing so people don't feel like they
missed out but I still feel like a
winner
yeah
be sure to credit them whoever they are
oh crap
wha what
what I don't see anything
what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong what could
possibly be wrong
what could be wrong I don't see anything
wrong was there was there was always two
speakers there the the linoleum was
always like this was wrong
what's wrong
oh no come on that is fine oh
no no no I came so far I survived the
thing I might have all just died at the
thing something doesn't seal right in
here I don't know Leisure him
oh [__]
what got fixed I don't know was
something down I don't know
I did it
something did feel raw oh the toilet
seats down in here
oh
it was right in front of me duh
all right so I got one chance left and
I'm still going
shockingly I'm still going just fix the
two anomalies that probably were the
only two that were caught gonna give me
a game over
I'm still in it somehow
crap
I'm not in it
crap no
no not like this no no
no come on give me an obvious one please
is there always a boss up there I don't
know was there probably
uh
I'm boned oh come on
[Music]
I have no idea
oh god
oh all that time what was different I
swear I've been staring at this [__] for
so long
why did I want to do this today I have
no idea wait a minute that
that reflection in that mirror doesn't
feel right
that mirror reflection doesn't seem is
that right
frick it was God
something is different where's the plant
that's different that dresser is
different that dresser is different
there was a plant under yeah
okay
all right okay
I'm starting to get the vibe starting to
get the feeling so if I can just keep a
hold of that feeling that like
something's weird
then I'll be good
hi ma'am
hello how are you
have a good day
oh oh work no play makes Jack dull boy
you bet it do
you better do
I remember that from the Bible
what pillows pillows pillows pillows
pillows
no idea how
I swear I would have looked at
everything by now right like how do you
some doesn't feel right in this run the
Leisure room I don't know why
no God damn it
what was that what what
I don't even know what anomaly that
would qualify as
the LSD just kicked in
what is what is that
what is that has that been there no no
way
I'm gonna come back to that
if I get a too many anomalies alert I'm
going to that because that don't look
that itches my brain like I would have
seen that
I wouldn't notice that right
am I crazy well there's a painting back
here but I never noticed it before was
that always there oh no
I don't know
oh frick how is this one so impossible I
really had Ambitions when I said if I
passed you something to first try idiot
oh
trash can it's just making me crazy
because I haven't even gotten the two
anomaly warning
it's making me feel like I'm crazy not
getting any so I start to panic
okay so that painting definitely was
back there whatever that was on the wall
why does this centerpiece look different
that looks different but I
I guess I've looked in the periphery so
much I'd never looked at the center
because why would I have done that
but it's sticking out in my head is
something different
but is it
what else would have been there
I know that there's something like that
object there
but was it that object
there was something like that there I
think it was this
it's just like this doesn't seem right
for some reason
well if that's it I'm gonna be so pissed
I'm at three o'clock again and I'm down
to two strikes
ah I'm here one strike left
oh no
okay there's my weld there's that
Leisure room
TV definitely I can go and fix that
is it that is it this is it this
[Music]
what the frick was that
it likes to do that just random tiny
noises every once in a while
I think anyway unless I'm crazy
which is very possible
and I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm dead I'm a dead man I
am dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm so dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm hello
how are you doing weird painting I'm
gonna ignore you
foreign
not dead yet
oh ask for me in my house we will devour
thy very Gods interesting how long has
that been like that that's two that's
two in a row am I back on top
I wasn't even looking at that sign
oh
I'm gonna see these rooms in my dreams
these are gonna go with me to My Grave
Just like I'm gonna have nightmares
about this house because I will have
memorized the interior structure so
intensely that I'll never be able to
forget it
I don't like that
I don't want this house in my mind
whoa
was that like that last time
was that like that
I don't know
dong four o'clock am I gonna make it to
six feels like this one is slower for
some reason I don't know why
oh head head kitchen head kitchen head
there's a head up there another head
found another head
good great great
this is the end for me
not at four I had okay another head all
right okay maybe not the end for me but
the end for you definitely sorry about
that that's not my problem though I have
a problem of getting through this next
hour and a half
with my ass intact
which is going to be difficult
there was there was something on here
something something is something
something's missing oh God oh God I I
know there is there's something missing
from here there is something missing
right there it was something on that
heater
yes yes yes yes yes
that was probably one of the Obscure
ones
I knew that there was something there oh
my God do not do not do not get out get
out get out don't
don't you do it oh you do it
are you kidding me
oh outside no no
I forgot about the concept of outside
you [__] oh well I got I have to have
it memorized by now
there was nothing there God wait unless
that is what's missing
that thing was not there I let that stew
for so long I am dumb
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
I thought I heard something oh my God oh
my God and I put it outside oh my God
I thought I heard something weird that
was like really really itching the back
of my mind
was that just like a super high pitch
for my ears hurt what the frick was that
this room is uncomfortable
I just don't like that room anymore
I just I don't like it I don't want any
part of it God
just don't want any part of it
oh my God what is wrong with me
how am I seeing nothing
I've been staring at this house for so
long
wait the bed's different wait a minute
the bed's different
well that's completely off
that's better
all right now what else
what else have I missed what else is
staring at me right in the face that I'm
not seeing
the plant always there
I'm just going to report this one
because I cannot shake the feeling of
something's weird I don't recall there
being a plant there but there probably
was
weird
damn it well I'm boned oh the chairs in
the kitchen are weird
oh the beer bottle moved in the game
room
I can notice details like that I know
that
I know that so it's like everything else
must be just as innocuous just as
minuscule just this
[Music]
two o'clock I'm not gonna make it even
close
man these the time goes so slow in this
level it goes so slow
and I'm missing it I'm about to game
over
oh chairs missing an ear God how long
has that been staring at me Frick I knew
something was wrong in here
there's a chair missing God
God ah that was probably one of the
Obscure ones God damn it oh why can't it
be the heads in jars
why can't it be creepy dude in the
closet why has it got to be one pillow
moved a millimeter I would have had it
if it had if I'd known the outside thing
and immediately I didn't know the
outside thing but I never executed upon
the outside thing
oh my God
[Music]
um
yeah I know the feeling bro
yeah I get you
Jesus well that was unexpected
um I want to go back to chairs Missy
I feel like this game is listening to me
or something
they're like it's trying to get a read
on me like by now I'm pretty familiar
with this space
like I'm very familiar with it
so I would think I would think that
something would jump out of me if it was
different
which is not I'm I'm at a loss
I'm at a loss how
how is it getting away with this
uh
are you uh
ah
what what is different
what is different
what what what
I'm dead wait a minute the carpet's
different no wait wait wait wait stop
let me report it
no thank you
okay I'm still in it shockingly
but barely
probably like seconds away from my
demise
three o'clock wow halfway there and I'm
doing so good
what was that
oh I don't know you're not gonna get
away with that one in the hallway again
I know that's not there I know that's
not supposed to be there I know that
ah
back in it maybe
I think I'm still like One Missed
anomaly away from death
and I'm dead I'm dead again I am dead I
feel it
kitchen kitchen painting painting
painting painting I'm not dead I'm not
dead I'm alive I'm alive I'm alive I
think I get a get a subconscious
notification of when there's an anomaly
I must have a sixth sense about this
and I just know or I've got an internal
clock that's telling me when I'm
missing out on something horrible and
I'm about to die but either way whatever
works
it's that thing also where when you look
at it out of the corner of your eye
these pictures just look monstrous
so I have to like study him for longer
whoop no no no no no no no no you're not
gonna do that to me these switched I
know that I know that
I know that okay I might be catching up
I might just be catching up I might be
might be catching up
up or parlor oh I might be catching up
okay that's three in like a very short
span which should have gotten me a
little bit ahead
because if one of those was something
that I missed in the past or if there
was another one in the room at the same
time I should be doing good
okay
oh hi buddy hi buddy yeah you whoa whoa
whoa what's going on hey dude look I'm
sorry I'm sorry for intruding I'm sorry
were you gonna pull me back there to be
sucked into your other worldly dimension
what am I missing
what am I missing what am I missing I'm
missing something
toilet seat is up that's in the right
spot coat rack all that stuff believe
that lady
two pillows three pillows oh what am I
missing
oh okay you're outside you're outside
you're outside outside you stay outside
good God okay all right
hello
painting that's different
good to know I don't need to hang around
[Music]
why does it feel weirdly quiet in that
last room I don't know why
oh no
oh I was looking at those as if they
were normal
[Music]
oh I don't know this planet plant there
oh maybe there was a plan missing on the
top of the TV
that feels like it was standing out to
me oh God it takes so long
High decapitated head
how are you I hope you're the first
anomaly I really hope you are
oh my God okay
that's fun thank you for that preach
thank you thank you really appreciate it
good to know that informational
information that you inform me of thank
you for that something feels different
in here for some reason I can't
imagine why no it's the same
no why does that why did that feel
different
I've been doing this too long my brain
is breaking
hello how are you okay I think I was
overreacting because it ramps up in
speed it ramps up in the number of
anomalies as time goes on so I'm looking
for things that aren't there but then
again maybe I'm not maybe there is
something that
should be super obvious but I'm not
seeing it
uh-huh
oh hello sir hello sir
hello sir outside the window
hello
uh-huh what
oh are you outside
I had to go look up uh some things that
could possibly be changed in this and
there are
so many
and so minutely
this is fine the rug is gone in the
kitchen the rug is gone
of course
of course the rug is gone
oh of course the rock is gone
wasn't there a plan here there's a plant
missing in the Leisure room
there's a plant missing
I think
okay
we might have a chance
the other crazy thing that can happen is
this can be flipped upside down all the
other crap I was looking at didn't
matter none of it mattered
didn't matter at all
didn't oh I see you the chair is
different I know that because I know
that
I have experienced that
yet
oh beer bottle is in a different spot I
really cannot screw up the outside thing
I really cannot screw that up
whatever I do I can't screw that up
you gotta stop that
okay oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God
oh my God
oh my God no oh my God
huh
ah
I am stressed
I'm stressed I feel like I'm missing
something I don't know how I literally
looked up where the things would be
how would I be missing something
I don't know whoa hey dude what are you
I said eyeball
okay
how long has that been looking at me and
I never saw it
I Don't Wanna Know
what in the hell
is that
please tell me that wasn't announced I
think
[Applause]
great yeah
that's that's
it's all very normal
just a normal house sitting gig
just a normal everyday
all is good kind of work job thing
oh trash can different in the kitchen
in the kitchen inside it
okay I got there
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
aha how long no it's out
[Applause]
oh
laughs
[Music]
oh my God you don't know how long I
spend recording that it was cut down but
my
God I can't do it it takes 30 minutes to
go six hours in that level I don't feel
like it was like that in the other ones
but that one took 30 goddamn minute yes
I don't have 30 million minutes so I
gotta go thank you everybody so much for
I was hoping for a quick relaxing uh
[Applause]
uh I will never do this again ever ever
in forever and forever ever ever ever
bye-bye